he totally copied me I did hi my name is
Lauren hi my name is Kimberly I am done
yet
hi I'm Zane and we are competing today
to match Arabic words to Spanish words
I've been practicing a little Arabic
from time to time you know I'm saying
for the ladies as we are women are hot
oh yes so my parents are from Syria so I
learned Arabic growing up sometimes you
know my friends who speak Spanish and I
understand a word here and there so yeah
there are a lot of great similarities
plus these both make bomb a sweet words
that's right I remember even learning
Spanish hearing the word bundle on is
there yes and we say a bunch of on oh
you ready I got it I got a baby I got it
don't be scared
[Laughter]
[Music]
do you not papi me oh my god I'm just
gonna guess for that one we're doing a
lot of guessing
yeah they horrible I think I did pretty
okay a lot of these words sounds so
similar I panicked but you did pretty
good though you put them up there I
tried Hadassah
so he toughie I matched with zouna sort
of pseudo Fah
so Jennifer giraffe right yeah I got a
blank so mascara is Misrata that's hot
oh so hot of it I matched with this word
is it that one Sara yes yes
so son Diaz watermelon and I matched it
with this word is they both started with
the same letter and ended with the same
letter ish totally copied I did
I see no it means murdered half a seed
right we women look at that okay
teamwork makes the dream work
would you I'm good job thank you
good job tea - I think we did good yeah
I think we did terrible but okay I think
I did okay there were a couple of things
that I mixed up we tried our best
you know what I feel like we bonded
that's all that matters at the end of
the day that's how we want
I learned that Spanish really is so
similar to Arabic yeah and that they're
both such well for one beautiful
languages I love that the words were so
similar that when you were saying them
in Spanish I thought they were actually
the Arabic word I think I would be able
to navigate a spanish-speaking country
one because there's a lot of similar
words to Arabic and I found in English
too
I think I learned that Arabs people have
a lot of like we are going to hang out